and i just want to say to the kids out
there watching you can do
anything you want in life yeah
yeah unless jay leno wants to do it too
listen to this happy birthday to jay
leno 61 years old today jay of course
one of the few tyrants still alive
and they
all of his friends got together and had
a party they had a cake and the jay
this is interesting point jay cut the
cake with the same knife he stuck in
conan's back
[Applause]
with the blinking midnight i don't know
the first thing about it but now i got
it on television stays on after midnight
how about how about how about shut up
[Applause]
though i am glad that the only person
whose ratings
uh fell more than mine last year is here
tonight great to see you jay
i'm also glad that i'm speaking first
because we've all seen what happens when
uh somebody takes the time slot after
leno's
and so they went to jay big jaw leno and
they said
uh jay uh we're taking your show away
from you yes
and uh jason yeah okay that's pretty
good
yeah i was gonna suggest that
what's the best prank you ever pulled i
told the guy i told a guy that
five years from now i'm gonna give you
my show and then when the five years
came i gave it to him and then i took it
back almost instantly
well do something about your body look
at your body i've seen him in a shower
the water misses him
okay look at your notes johnny i'm
asking about your anniversary say
something when is your anniversary
no that's why there's somebody insulting
things about you well i don't care get
over where did you go did you take her
somewhere did you travel i know you're
looking to take her it's not
yeah here barbara here roll over here
uh jay leno now is being replaced and
this is the second time this has
happened
yes i mean it's crazy uh he's being
replaced by a younger
late-night talk show host what could
possibly go wrong
honestly what but the nbc uh god bless
announced uh the official date for jay
leno's departure
uh no mention of his official date of
return
however so i don't know when that'll
take place
right i did stand stand-up comedy in
boston when i was 18.
jay leno was the big star and so i've
known him a long time and i know conan
and he's a great guy and
so it's weird when you get to be in a
position where you actually know the
players
right so it's not just sort of people on
tv you really know them and you know
their families and you know
you have a history with them and i just
felt it was a crappy thing to do you
know that conan had
had been working 17 years for that
company and then
you know jay was told five years ago
that it was his turn to give up the
driver's seat
right right that is not his bus that's a
60-year bus that's been driving around
the country that tonight so and if
you're lucky enough to get to drive it
when they say hey you're done you give
the keys back and you say thank you you
don't flatten the tires or the guy who
comes next you know
so to me i don't know crappy thing
look at you look at you very dapper here
look at him look at him with the
cigarette here look at this kind of
of course i was a handsome young guy mr
continental had a few bad breaks and
that's it
but i was young then and those were
those were the days when bill cosby and
bob newhart the button-down mind of bob
newart
and those were the days when albums were
big you know and now that's over with
and i'm on this
right but uh and jay
of course all jay keeps saying is yeah
you know i think there's room for
everybody
saying to people well what what has he
done wrong he's just kind of doing
what the network tells him to do you
know they say jay
go to 10. yeah okay not a bad idea right
so they they say they say jay all right
jade the ten o'clock didn't work come
back to 11 30.
okay sure if that's what you want right
what's the most number of lap dances
you've had in one night
jay my mother's watching the show so
actually no wait a minute the show's
canceled right nobody's watching the
show
well first of all let's look at the
history of jay leno jay leno pushed
johnny carson out of the tonight show
that was number one
and he did it in a merciless way and
then uh dave letterman who wanted the
job okay he didn't get the job
fair enough but look at the integrity of
a david letterman
david letterman was rejected by nbc he
was told he's being passed over for the
job
did he sit there like a dog and take
that from
nbc no he did what any man would do he
got up and he moved over to cbs and took
over the show
right now jay leno on the other hand
seems to be the kind of showbiz animal
that will not let go
here is a guy who worked on the tonight
show for 17 years he was number one in
his time slot
right he gets uh fired by nbc they put
on conan o'brien what would you do as a
man
wouldn't you go to another network if
you don't make parties
if you don't make partner you're
supposed to leave and go to another firm
listen i'm gonna tell you something i've
worked for many people and been fired by
them i was fired by nbc many years ago
you know what i did i didn't sit there
like a lap dog and take it
i got up i brushed myself off and i went
on terrestrial radio on a competing
station
and i buried nbc into the ground that's
what you do
jay should have dusted himself off gone
to another network he certainly had the
money and the offers right and he should
have gone and beaten conan and beaten
dave and beaten jimmy kimmel
all these guys not too good at gambling
and never played never played bridge
never played poker did you
no i'm not a gambler at all actually
what do you do well i do what you
do i i go to vegas i do you sit around
all day long
i know what you do
uh mavis the damn thing is stuck again
wow and mavis is underneath the hood
going i'll fix it jay
now what do you do what do you do in las
vegas none of your business
years ago when nbc said to jay you know
what conan's gonna take over your job in
five years
that's when you say okay fine no hard
feelings you call abc you call fox
you try to get my job you leave you
don't you don't yeah
okay but if i'll be in the lobby you
know if you need
don't hang around
[Music]
what do you fear most i fear the network
will move my show to 10 o'clock
right
i honestly think that tonight's show
stopped when johnny carson retired what
the hell else are they talking about
yes that's 35 years yeah that's charlie
carson that's johnny carson's show that
tonight we'll do another show now
i agree do another show but the swarming
thing was you know jay saying you know
my show didn't work and then they said
to me hey you wanna go on for a half
hour i said oh sure
he's going okay with that no he's not
okay with that
[Applause]
is he it's not okay
i had dancing hands i don't know because
my father what's the soul he mean
dancing hands dancing hand what are you
a [ __ ] don't you know what dancing
hands are
dancing hands about dancing hands like
this from the nerves oh i see you mean
you're nervous
what else smart as a whip yes yeah
you know you're scary you got this big
show you make 40 million dollars a year
and you guessed this means you're
nervous a lot of these
i can't believe it i'm working with a
scientist
jay wants to do we know two things about
jay he likes to tell jokes at eleven
jokes at eleven yeah any and he works on
he has an old truck he works
an old truck he loves he loves getting
in there to tinker
uh-huh hey mammoth bring me some bring
me some motorola davis bring me some
motoring
give me bring me some quaker skates
is there anything you haven't hosted
that you want to host
oh this is a trick right you get me to
host the tonight show and then take it
back from no no no no
i'm not gonna say you got dancing hands
as you were dancing hands you never let
up on that
no no i guess i hope you go to cedars
and my cousin's your doctor
and standing over the bed and jay goes
and they have to say all right just sit
quiet we're gonna punch you once and
hope the jaw snaps up
oh your burgers oh
take a look at him he can't drink a soda
without dribbling all over himself
come on let's be honest for god's sake
this man's a moose you put him over the
fireplace nobody's gonna know the
difference
and he said that uh we should not blame
conan for what's going on
don't blame conan don't blame conan for
what's going on
and i said to myself no one is blaming
[Music]
i hope you're not planning on blaming
conan are you
well i wasn't i i mean in the thousands
and thousands of words that have been
printed about this mess
who has blamed conan no one i don't
think so
no one has blamed conan
john mccain is the uh new president uh
ladies and gentlemen
and uh he says that life is a pow had no
effect on him
but rumor has it he just installed a
water board outside the white house pool
guess i might be going swimming over
there will i
all right so uh john mccain i had his
arms repeatedly broken
during captivity and to this day he
can't raise his arms above his shoulders
i guess that explains
dude i can't